o lado pessoal de quem fala lugar que
sejam muito bem vindos em mais um vídeo
e hoje traz jack meu primeiro vídeo em
34 é que o comando mínimo gostoso
incluindo se agora muito recentemente o
jogo reside não só não utiliza do
residente no set eu nunca escrevi ps4
portanto aproveitar já que seja um jogo
que eu gosto e eu tive que contar que é
coisa de time misto comandou ontem um
carro-bomba junto meu muita coisa aqui
só para conseguir fazer um vídeo simples
e não precisa por nenhuma de placas de
captura e com solução que possa me amam
tanto que contará com o e carros mas
acho que vai resultar tanto para lá
pessoal estar aqui
a linguagem que a pesquisa linguagem
chinês tem arábico tem japanese em
inglês preenche frente ou então e ano
geru [ __ ] o nobel português toque
brasil e em portugueses agora subtítulo
o nome claro sempre quando você pode em
nenhuma inglês
a nex ok é que temos a aflição do gana
vamos ter aqui um pouquinho pessoal eu
vou tentar fazer este vídeo com menos
cortes possíveis porque eu sei que isto
é um daqueles jogos desse mais séries
margem tem 15 tanto eu vou tentar não
gostar tanto é só falar andar jogar e
para lá começou mais um sorriso e rápido
está muito gostoso este gráfico resident
evil 7 pisa penning hour para buscar uma
hora de uma hora sem cortar só falar e
não vão alcançar o sul o que você já só
saí da casa
é muita realidade para mim isto tabu e
aula
expresse o filme muda com juro em 2 a
casa é possível lá tem isso aqui ó
então nós começamos dentro de uma queda
está muito alto
começamos dentro desta crise não é e já
tem aqui a dívida samara samara está
cheia e olha o leitor e deixo a noite
tenha essa você não tem uma fita de
vídeo pois não eu não tenho nada porque
eu comecei agora eu sou pobre eu não
tenho culpa nenhuma
op é minha família e minha mãe eo meu
pai que vê no bai e foi isto pai porque
foi lá acho que eu sei que tu taxa e a
casa presta pra nada mesmo sexo achei
que o tanque inclusive no youtube
pessoas lá em cima da hora é do demônio
tá bom eu acho que tem que baixar isto o
que é que eu não sei como é que se baixe
o som luz natural existe no quadro eu
não sei só sei que preciso mas vamos
agora está faltando inclusivel a um ok
vamos ter que apanhar um fusível então
esse é o nosso primeiro objetivo
agora vamos só explorar um pouquinho que
serias keys bisturi para aí alguém do ac
já disputados com coisinhas não gosto
está uma casa drogas têm um papel
o show ontem à noite 11 anos
eu estou agora a inês pedras agora 2.800
não ok quando ela voltar aqui acho que
não há nada né
vamos lançar vamos avançar que presta a
portinha se é que não está fechada né
porque estas curtas a uma festa na porta
a porta
vamos lá a à espera de nada de lá fora
ai caraças não isso é muita textura do
meu estado estamos bem o seu papel
lá atrás discordo segundo meu tabu é
real este gráficos como assim apenas 45
assim escalar é sempre assim deixando 48
habituado a jogar como eu pensei com uma
placa de vídeo gosta escalar o tempo
disse que estava na bom quando na
verdade tudo jogos apenas quatro são
bons mas não saí [ __ ] espanha e aula
olha aqui cozinha já a amil é muita
coisa por explorar o o alguma coisa lá
em cima
ontem eu vi uma luz do exterminador
implacável vamos falar cozinha fundação
em cima andando e sim isto tá mesmo
abandonado também muito abandonada tenho
porque está tudo sustenta já tem alguém
dentro da casa eu tenho alguém lá em
cima
wilson rodrigues alves não engana vamos
explorar a cozinha então eu tenho que
encontrar um fusível ae
parem com esse para olhos tudo morre e
vamos explorar o frigorífico pode ser
como o pai tenha concordado com um
fusível dentro do frigorífico
a louis delicioso vinho
hum inseto jó e tem um pacote china sul
é uma massa juízo muitos paulo anda lá
eu não pensei [ __ ] nenhuma massa gil só
comia tipo aquela coisa o que aquela não
se chama rameh não é o flamengo ainda
não comi também vai [ __ ] funda surra
média ataque mais barulho funda surratt
e miojo emergência mas é isso aí eu não
sei mas eu tô com medo quando a questão
panela ó panela com tecnologia para lá e
uma panela com os cras aéreas
agora esse hospital é muito gostoso uma
vez que o milan não está muito bom ontem
que uma torneira está em coisas como a
interação o que é muito bom
agora eu não sei o que eu vou à procura
de um fusível é isso é isso não vamos
perder o objetivo claro que não vamos
perder qualquer um que tenha um corpo
morto dentro do micro-ondas adora sptel
também é muito gostoso
o collecta the year neste momento sinto
medo porque o secretário de alguém fora
se o seu tipo arrombar uma porta assim
eu sei que a insegurança agora há mais
coisas produtor ou transplantar aqui não
há armários
eu acho que há fator fogão eu não vi o
fogão aqui é só o shopping é que está lá
fora é só treinarão a parar umas flores
a água está boa e eu não sei talvez
produtos e dentro de casas e fora eu não
sai mas vamos também continuar e alguém
chutar de fora por duas a dora cordoso
olha só essa teia da aranha estava em
alta está muito gostosa e que tem um
armário ou da palavra isto está
acorrentado estava já tudo eu já tenho
que correr entrado em campo já que o
martelo realmente essa merda
ano a ano a seduc bicho vai ser aqui
ok animais foi transmitir lhes parece
não ser aquelas quintas nem com animais
olha só o animal todos tripulado uma
vaca tem vaca né meu deus tá muito ficou
preso que cortador de vergalhão ganhar
vamos lutar por ele é wesley
olha não estou milhão aplicado em 1
bilhão vai purificar o inventário ok não
era preciso avisar emma sempre verificar
o inventário o peixe ficou mais calma
vissem com mais calma agora o que têm
que fazer o julgamento por executar
correntes ao caí roca eu vou usar isso
então por encurtar a língua mario atrás
né
a descer isso eu acho que é ok mas antes
disso não só confirmará quis esta porta
está aberta
você precisa de uma chave para sair
quem é e precisamos de uma chave mas não
temos a chave ainda portanto vamos
apanhar a chave dentro do armário
é eu sei que estou e uma coisas dentre
as coisas entraram em outra porta e
sempre assim
lá a imagem da casa abandonada não
conseguir o resto mas é uma cacetada
aqui nós vamos poder viajar sair vamos
ter que ir atrás então para lá espera lá
vamos tudo para trás e vamos ver por
capacetes dentro do leito [ __ ] inicial
estava lá atrás lembram seu lembro eu
saiba mais no clube só vai vai
eu sei que vou fazer agora eu tô anos
vamos entrar que vocês vão ver que um
demônio dentro só agora quer para quem a
equipe do nexo enfrentados o teto não
abra gostoso adoro assim é aqui
cai nada se passou nada explosivo lanz
acho que a áfrica teve comigo ok então
não apareceram aqui pra não ir adiante
nem foi só aqui e não lá há agora tem
colecionado tá muito do estigma de
inventário também da fifa caso haja
também deverá caxeta de rex aux de um
duro e alta calça e imparcial a folha
serviço em inglês era uma merda eles
estão no ar sua câmera agora a foto e
vídeo a água não estou a falar eu mesmo
assim [ __ ] se eu quero ajudar sim
pessoal eu saí e esteve segunda que o
senhor crucificado em história
eu quero é jogar eu acho estranho lá na
porta do filme acompanha tudo sinto
agora só maria possas aquino a sai da
frente que ok isso ela é forte a vai-vai
jones vai abrir a porta e isso eu não
sei se chama jonas jonas lá agora deixou
a câmera me passado em houston quem sabe
é bravo
será que está assombrada melgaço ainda
pergunta está assombrada botafoto olha
só isso porém partida tão estranha que a
nova estação brava
meu isto parece as lutas do naruto e eu
estou eu estou apurado um com o outro
mas foi aguente lá no meio das ruas mas
sim foi varrido esse espectro
o jogo era eu quero que o filme uma
panela já que eu já vim acho que não tem
baratos agora época então está mesmo
passava algumas etapas são lucas andré
pessoal andré acabou de ser raptado
pelos tumores na casa assombrada de
lugar com o euro cai um avião numa casa
assombrada trabalho não o encontrou
andré e do andré
não não foi isso vai lá na frente
já no sentido centro o matrimônio sentir
o cheiro a enxofre é nesta sala que
possua preparem se
andou lá meu deus ayew vai querer agora
o retrato né
eu estou a entrar dentro da orelha
olha houve um bom lugar do pac que nem
brincar era uma passagem discreta foi
vaiado e é legal nem photoshop em bora
bora bora bora bora bora fazer show
vamos encontrar o andré
agora eu gostava de ir contigo a exata
er 13h chan era isso mesmo que eu ia
perguntar e vai em tutoriais um chá em
fazer um bom trabalho ganhou vantagem no
trecho a trecho seja quer ficar no lote
e isso eu e 53 4 agora não vou para a
cama
então vamos folhas nó folha só tamanho
real expresso no filme
a câmera conta com as duas mãos na
câmara
eu já estou vendo eu estou vendo pedras
e muita pedra
andré morreu morreu e outro foi aqui que
tudo aconteceu aqui fazer essas coisas
não pode ser só bonita isso tem uma
pessoa aqui fazer magnata umas às outras
não pode ser a oca aí agora o que eu
tenho agora tem que ver quem né
izarra exata eu acho que tem que vir
aqui tudo bem que foi só um pingo de
molho não anda lá o que é baixo e que
irá até aqui exatamente aqui esta coisa
cultura abriu passagem discreta
nós temos que ir agora não é essa
agora temos que colocar lá né ainda
tenho que apanhar uma chave por sair
daqui de casa quem achava que a outra
porta e não esquece xiita que tem
objetivos
nós temos que encontrar um fusível e
temos que encontrar uma chave e é isso
que nós temos que fazer e agora vou
procurar aqui vestindo tênis teixeirinha
não achei mg que vamos em frente bora lá
seguir embora a chave da porta olhem com
três shopping o falar a sério tão
previsível tal prevê encerrar o ano lá
só para aquela porta né
vamos lá em busca do assassino do jec
teve seu sonho de subir o piloto
eu era foi por si listas estou bem aqui
pera lá eu sei que não tive muito tempo
aqui estavam a dizer eu acho que o homem
era strike
eu nem sei se referiram em si só não
gera foi possível este homem
eu já não saí olha eu já não sair eu vou
enfrentá e o que acontecer aconteceu eu
não quer sair e vamos lá com sua força
máxima
eu não fui lá acima ainda por cima
porque ainda não brincar cima e eu quero
explorar toda a manequim a dor como eu
adoro in loco adoro adoro quente
alguma coisa deve ser um fusível não é
de ferro né
quem não estava aqui era eu não só três
não eram olha eu já saí eu já cheguei
aqui eu acho que ficar confuso já estou
a ver coisas que não existem anda solar
para baixo
já temos a chave é o que interessa vamos
abrir a porta fora só resta lá
isso na peça é mais intenso é muito mais
intenso e o sistema eu acabei de estar
com ela tentou falar não dá para falar
antes não dá já deixou sem casa não não
ter agora precisa nem por isso na pele
olha ela é o pai era o pai mas faltou a
china está a ser a experiência traz um
cd que o andrés já morreu
olha o traste pronto já foste tu tá bom
então isso quer dizer que eu era essa
pessoa que está amarrado certo
apareceu um chupa-cabra agora que um
demônio eu já não sei condição eu já não
sei existe mori é o pai eu não saibam
que [ __ ] nenhuma
a família está esperando você início de
abra a porta para o programa de
embaixadores residentes eo pessoal
espero que vocês tenham gostado aqui
neste dia seguinte vamos tirando certo e
como vocês viram eu andei muitos cortes
importantes para as escolas têm a mesma
eu sei que isso não é bom e mostrou do
vídeo mas eu esperava que isso fosse um
pouco mais sério e foi eu contava que eu
tivesse mais sutil mostrou mesmo assim
eu gostei pra caramba estou ansioso pelo
jogo e vamos lá ver o que é que o resto
do mundo que não vai ser nem no futuro e
é isso que eu estou aqui tudo bonito
para um estado que na linha